one
bueno pues yo les voy a platicar sobre
rendirse me siento muy afortunado porque
en estos 13 años que llevo creando
contenido he tenido la oportunidad de
hacer cosas super locas para los vídeos
pero la vez que me tocó y tuve la
oportunidad de ir a un safari estaba muy
nervioso
héctor lo único que tienes que hacer
para sobrevivir es no abrir la puerta y
no bajar la ventana para tomar una foto
porque cuando escuchas que alguien se lo
come un león en un safari es porque
abrió la puerta o bajó la ventanilla no
lo hagas no lo hagas llegas a firmar un
contrato y dice pues es tu
responsabilidad tú decides si te come el
león es porque la naturaleza lo quiso
así
y ya firme que bueno que llegó al coche
estoy listo
vemos el coche y el coche no tiene ni
puertas ni ventanas así que no había
nada que abrir nada que cerrar nada que
subir y nada que bajar entonces estuve a
seis metros de tres leones adultos sin
nada entre nosotros y aún así no tuve
tanto miedo como cuando decidí terminar
una una relación que no me estaba
haciendo bien o cuando decidí dejar un
proyecto a medias aunque ya le había
invertido tiempo y dinero no no me dio
tanto miedo como cuando decidí cambiarme
de carrera porque descubrí que no era lo
mío
entonces nos da mucho miedo y rendirnos
tiene muy mala fama porque nos han
enseñado que tenemos que seguir nuestros
sueños que tenemos que aferrar nos
cueste lo que cueste lo que no nos damos
cuenta es que a veces el costo somos
nosotros mismos y nos abandonamos para
poder llegar a esas metas que a veces
realmente son imposibles y tomamos
decisiones incorrectas y antes de que
ghana y estos millennials ahora quieren
hacer cool rendirse y quieren dejar de
trabajar y no no se trata de dejar de
trabajar y no se trata de dejar de amar
sino de tomar decisiones y hacer uno a
las preguntas correctas sin tener miedo
a saber la verdad
porque nos da miedo
nos da mucho miedo el cambio y yo
encontré dos razones primero porque nos
estamos contando una historia cuando le
pones tanto esfuerzo a una relación a un
proyecto a tu carrera se empieza a
borrar la línea entre donde terminas tú
y dónde comienza el proyecto sientes que
tú eres tu relación sientes que tú eres
tu carrera y a mí me ha pasado mi
trabajo me ha dado tanto que digo si a
mí me quitan mi trabajo yo no soy nada
yo no valgo en vez de decir si no fuera
por mí no estaría mi trabajo entonces
nos entregamos lo damos todo nos
sacrificamos tratamos de salvar una
relación que nos está haciendo más daño
que bien no dormimos mal comemos nos
maltratamos y nos ha pasado que nos
dicen te quiero mucho pero no nos lo
demuestran y me ha pasado a mí conmigo
mismo es negligencia me digo te quiero
pero no estoy haciéndome un bien
luchando por estos proyectos porque les
doy más valor a ellos que a mí pero les
voy a platicar
hay varios pasos en nuestra manera de
pensar para que pueda funcionar primero
que nada cada quien su ensalada
esto es como estos restaurantes uso
muchas analogías de comida porque me
encanta comer estos restaurantes en los
que está en un menú y viene de que tú
seleccionas tu lechuga tu proteína este
si quieres que lleve para necesito si
quieres que lleve aceite yo no conozco
tu vida entonces tú decides con qué
rendirte y con qué no y cuando somos
suficientemente valientes como para
hacernos esas preguntas de hoy es esto
algo que le he puesto tanto esfuerzo no
está haciendo bien o me está haciendo
mal vas a saber qué cositas tachar en tu
menú entonces cada quien su ensalada tú
decides no vayas a llegar a tu casa de
que te voy a cortar porque no viene una
plática no
[Risas]
la otra razón además de esto es el
sistema límbico por eso sentimos tanto
miedo escuché sobre esto que hace que
nos dé miedo estar en estas situaciones
pero le pregunté a mis papás ya mi
hermano porque todos son doctores yo soy
la vieja bloguero de la familia
y el sistema límbico es eso que está
nuestra cabecita que no servía antes nos
sirvió para sobrevivir cuando había
pumas en la calle bueno no había calles
pero había pumas entonces te encuentras
como una amenaza y tú y el sistema
límbico te dice alerta alerta te vas a
morir estás en peligro pero el sistema
límbico no distingue entre un león y tu
ex no distingue entre un león y una
tarea entonces lo único que sabe es que
estás en peligro y tienes que estar en
alerta
entonces le has puesto tanto esfuerzo y
trabajo a estos proyectos a tu relación
a tu trabajo que te sientes amenazado tú
mismo aunque no seas tú es tu
calificación es una relación y tenemos
que aprender a separarnos de todas estas
situaciones pero esto hace el sistema y
es lo que nos ayuda a sobrevivir
entonces tampoco podemos hacerle el feo
entonces tenemos estas dos razones por
las cuales nos da tanto terror
para los que se estaban preguntando así
se vería si luchara contra un león más o
menos de hecho traemos el mismo outfit
es un pantalón de vestir así que es un
poco injusto porque él está desnudo pero
si yo estuviera desnudo podría ser un
poco más de daño
ok la primera vez que aprendí sobre las
ventajas de rendirse fue cuando tenía 11
años
todos los días llegando a la escuela
jugaba pokemon y era que todos los días
me concentraba en atrapar pokemon tras
pokemon y logre atrapar los 151 hasta mi
idea no en serio los 151 pokemon y
cuando atrapas todos te dan un diploma
no a ti sino al monito que estás
controlando entonces es un diploma
digital y todos los días después de
pasar el juego me metía y veía el dipló
mitad y luego pensé que aburrido tal vez
no se trata de pasarlo se trata de
volver a empezar ya mis 11 años tomé una
decisión super difícil borrar mi juego y
volver a empezar porque muchas veces
empezamos las cosas solo para terminar
las haces el examen de la carrera y
estás estudiando solo para terminar te
gusta alguien y haces todo tu esfuerzo
solo para andar se acabó el juego
ambas con alguien y tu meta es casarte
de casa se acabó el juego entonces pasan
todas estas cosas que inicias sólo para
terminar ya mis 11 años me di cuenta de
que tal vez no se trata de terminar el
juego sino de jugarlo
creciendo descubrí a los emprendedores
seriales mi favorito es richard branson
son estas personas que saben ellos son
más importantes que sus proyectos este
señor ha empezado empresas de trenes
celulares naves espaciales refrescos
unas han fallado horriblemente y otras
han triunfado pero sabe elegir cuáles y
cuáles no hay cuando salirse y pasar al
siguiente entonces por eso él es mi
favorito y cuando descubrí esto son
personas que en el mundo real les va muy
bien porque saben cuándo salirse de su
empresa de su proyecto sin dolor porque
tu valor más importante de tu proyecto
más importante eres tú
y también pasa mucho que como tienen
mala fama rendirse decimos es que lo más
fácil es rendirte pero no a veces lo más
fácil es seguir ahí haciendo lo mismo
todos los días y esto yo lo entendí con
el experimento de las ranas hay dos
ollas una con agua hirviendo y la otra
olla tiene agua a temperatura ambiente
en la olla con agua hirviendo meten una
rana y la rana siente el calor luego
luego install está haciendo el que
monitos no va a salvar no esta rana
sobrevive en la otra olla que tiene el
agua a temperatura ambiente mete la rana
y le van subiendo poquito a poquito por
la rana dice ah pues esto es como un
charco se siente bien agusto el agua
está a temperatura ambiente le van
subiendo pero es tan gradual y tan lento
que para cuando la rana se da cuenta que
el agua se está calentando ya está
hervida entonces la rana muere eso nos
pasa a nosotros cuando decimos no pasa
nada ya me di cuenta que no quiero
trabajar en esto pero ya llevo tres años
en esta carrera la voy a acabar y aquí
voy a seguir esta relación no me está
haciendo bien pero todos me dicen ay
güey aguanta todas estas cosas cuando
nos dicen poquito a poquito así estás
bien no pasa nada y te dices a ti
mismo es más fácil hacerlo que dejar de
hacerlo y no tomamos la decisión y
terminamos como la rama
otra cosa que me ayudó mucho para
decidir por qué es una gran decisión no
es cualquier cosa no es una decisión que
tomas de un día a otro el decidir
rendirte a mí me ayudó mucho
james cars y él tiene esto sobre los
juegos finitos e infinitos él dice que
todo el tiempo los seres humanos estamos
jugando dos tipos de juegos finitos e
infinitos un juego finito es un juego de
soccer dura determinado tiempo y al
final alguien gana alguien pierde que
mete más goles se acabó el juego un
juego infinito es ser fan del soccer
siempre va haber nuevas playeras siempre
vas a tener que comprar entradas siempre
va a haber nuevos jugadores si eres fan
de un equipo aunque haya nuevos
jugadores sigue siendo fan entonces ese
es un juego infinito un juego infinito
es cuando estás con tu novio con tu
novia de cuelga tú no tú cuelga y cuando
cuelga de qué tanga y lo anotas no eso
no pasa es un juego infinito entonces lo
llegué a ver como nuestra vida es un
juego infinito que tiene juegos finitos
dentro de ella si tienes un mal día ese
fue un juego finito si tienes un mal
momento es precisamente eso es un
finito tenemos que llegar a comprender
si lo que estamos haciendo es un juego
infinito o no y eso nos puede ayudar
bastante
millo del pasado algo que nos mantiene
mucho en una decisión es nuestra versión
de antes que tomó una decisión y nos
quedamos con ella millo del pasado lo
quiero mucho y a los 17 años él quiso
ser chef pero algo y se le quemaba el
jueguito entonces sí lo recuerdo con
cariño pero ese bato agarra fiesta con
aguas locas no voy a dejar que él elija
mi destino y muchas veces tienes 17 años
tomas una decisión y te quedas con ella
porque leer es más fiel a tu yo del
pasado que a tuyo del presente y eso nos
detiene mucho de tomar una decisión y
saber si es algo que todavía queremos
tal vez es algo que queríamos y en ese
momento era una buena decisión pero
ahora podemos ver frente a frente a
nuestro yo del presente y decir algo
diferente algo mejor para nosotros algo
que también pasa mucho es la falacia de
los costos hundidos
esto se trata sobre tratar de recuperar
algo que ya perdimos para siempre te
compras unos zapatos super
que te pones dos veces al año porque te
callas pero como ya gastaste te los
vuelves a poner vas al buffet te duele
la panza pero tienes que llegar al
postre y como ya pagaste ahí vas estás
en una relación de tres años y dices tal
vez y le inviertas 33 voy a recuperar
esos 3 no tenemos que entender ya lo
perdí solo puedo seguir a partir de
ahora y entender lo que ya perdimos no
lo vamos a recuperar
con que rendirte con la perfección con
el tratar de que las cosas salgan a la
perfección según nuestros criterios ser
tercos a veces pensamos que ser
perseverantes es igual a ser terco si no
es el querer tener resultados diferentes
haciendo lo mismo siempre el tratar de
tener siempre el control a veces hasta
somos tercos con nuestras debilidades
alguien nos dice una palabra tú eres así
tú eres débil y nos casamos con esa
palabra y nosotros nos definimos con esa
palabra tratamos a veces hasta de
defender nuestros propios límites
entonces hay que rendirnos con todas
esas cosas que nos limitan a veces por
tener cierta edad creemos que nos
debemos de comportarnos hacer ciertas
cosas también tenemos que rendirnos con
eso con las expectativas no te puedes
rendir con tu familia pero sí con las
expectativas que tienes de tu hijo de tu
hija entonces se trata de decidir entre
todos estos juegos y todas estas
palabras que nos hace bien y que nos
hace mal
por último vámonos a lo más básico la
palabra éxito todos la tenemos a nuestra
cabeza y se nos vienen mil cosas y él
el resultado puede ser algo que nos
dijeron nuestros papás maestros tíos
vecinos tu perro si tu perro habla
háblame de la salida
y al final la palabra éxito viene del
latín exitus que significa salida como
las puertas en inglés
el éxito tal vez significa el reconocer
o el entender cuando ya terminamos de
aprender de una persona de una situación
de una experiencia el poder reconocer
nuestros éxitos no te puedes rendir con
tus logros no te puedes de graduar
entonces si llegaste esta plática te
deseo que puedas reconocer el éxito que
a veces se esconde detrás de las puertas
que dicen salida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]